Marsha is if I say like who comes
[inaudible] Marsha say if I say like who
comes to see?
Marsha said,
if I say like you [inaudible]
good evening everyone.
Today I'm going to talk about how to
improve your listening comprehension in
the target language that you are
studying.
Now I should point out in advance,
I'm not talking to people who don't know
any of the language yet.
There's no point trying to improve your
listening comprehension if you don't
know the phonology,
the basic grammar and sentence structure
and basic vocabulary of the language.
Really I'm talking to people who are
already studying the language,
already know some of the basics,
but their listening comprehension is not
up to speed with their other skills and
other awareness of the language.
All right,
so the most important thing is to listen
to every day.
Consistency is king.
You want to practice listening every
day.
Make sure you are practicing listening
just as much as you are practicing
reading or practicing speaking or
learning grammar and vocabulary.
Spend just as much time on the listening
because obviously that's of key
importance when you want to communicate
with people.
So these days it's very easy to do every
day.
Even if you live in the middle of
nowhere.
If you have an internet connection,
you have no excuse to not practice the
listening.
When I studied Hebrew language back in
like 1997 in those days,
the Internet was just getting off the
ground.
There were very few resources.
You guys today are very lucky.
Make use of them.
You have a youtube videos,
all languages have,
you have videos available on Youtube.
I'm sure you can find something good
there.
Uh,
as well,
you can find streaming radio stations,
streaming news networks,
um,
streaming television stations.
You can find downloadable videos on
demand,
full movies and your target language.
You can find everything.
So make sure you get some of that.
No excuses.
Do it every day.
Okay.
One piece of advice I will give you is
to use videos and to use videos that
have subtitles.
So if you get a DVD,
sometimes you can set the subtitles on
so you can watch with the subtitles and
then maybe remove them.
Um,
but also on the internet you can find
videos that have been,
um,
they've had subtitles added to them as a
way to help second language learners.
Like I found a website for French that
had all sorts of movies with subtitles
added to them,
French movies that somebody added the
subtitles as a way to help second
language learners,
French learners.
So there are materials out there like
that with subtitles and those are very
useful for helping you make a connection
between the visual and the auditory.
Some people are more visual learners,
they need to understand the language
visually and conceptualize it visually.
And if you're just listening,
sometimes won't be able to perceive the
sounds until you make that connection
with the written word.
So the subtitles help you do that to
make that connection between the sound
and the visual.
And I recommend that you listen with the
subtitles first,
but then you can remove them if it's a
DVD and you can remove the subtitles
with the setting then do that.
But if the subtitles are kind of are,
they're already edited into the video
and you can't remove them,
then you can try it as closing your eyes
or covering your eyes.
You can do that.
I'm sure after you are already familiar
with the content of the video and you
know what it's about,
you know the the topic and stuff from
reading it,
then you can switch off the subtitles.
Just tried to rely on your hearing the
second time around and you are getting
rid of that visual crutch after you've
already made the connection between
auditory and visual.
Okay.
So watch once with subtitles once
without train yourself like that to just
listen,
I should say.
They'll be where of captions on Youtube
or any automatically generated captions.
They usually suck.
Sometimes they're hilarious.
So if you want a good laugh,
you can watch them and figure out what
they're saying.
Usually it's way off.
So just be careful.
The captions are not usually accurate.
Okay.
I recommend that you practice listening
to a variety of different levels.
So some materials out there are made for
second language learners.
So they are graded,
they use grated language that's aimed
at,
for example,
beginners or intermediate level or upper
intermediate,
the languages tailored for learners.
So it's simpler and it's easier for you
to grasp and understand.
So I recommend you use that sometimes
because that helps you consolidate the
things that you are learning in your
textbook,
the things that you are studying or the
things you learn in class from your
teacher.
If you use a simple video,
simple audio too that will help you
review and consolidate things you're
already learning.
And it's encouraging because it's,
it's not too far above your level,
not too far out of your comfort zone.
So you will be able to understand a lot
of it and that will be encouraging for
you and you'll feel that you're
improving and you're using the language
for something functional so you'll feel
good and encouraged.
But at the same time I recommend that
you use more difficult materials that
are aimed at native speakers.
So listen to the radio,
listen to the news,
watch TV shows,
that kind of thing.
And just experience the sound of the
language.
I recommend that you have no
expectations of understanding.
You just relax.
You don't put any pressure on yourself
to have good comprehension.
You just want to just hear the sounds of
the language and notice the things that
you recognize.
Even if you don't understand what's
being said,
just think,
ah,
I remember that word,
I've heard that before.
And notice the patterns of intonation.
Notice where if you notice where one
word starts and then ends or you notice
where the next word begins,
that's that's all fine.
Just notice that.
Don't worry about trying to understand.
You just want to internalize those
patterns subconsciously.
So then once you are study gets to that
level,
you will be very well prepared to to
understand it because you've already
internalized all of those auditory
patterns.
Okay,
so I recommend you listen to simpler
materials.
Also more challenging materials.
Just listen and experience the sounds.
That's it.
And the last thing I'll recommend is to
speak with native speakers.
Maybe it sounds obvious to some of you,
but a lot of people still just studying
books and they still,
they still just learn to read and write
and make sentences out loud in the
language without actually talking to
native speakers.
But these days with the Internet,
again,
you have no excuse.
You can go to [inaudible] dot com and
you can find a skype teacher.
Some of them are really cheap.
Depending on the language you're
speaking,
you can sometimes get a lesson for like
$5 per hour or $10 per hour is more
common.
Um,
it's,
it's cheap and it's effective.
You need to speak with native speakers
in your target language,
especially in an uncontrolled context.
Like if it's just,
I'm a very structured,
scripted lesson where they do listen and
repeat with you are they,
have you just read sentences and that
kind of thing that's not as beneficial.
You want to have some surprises.
You want it to be uncontrolled so that
you,
you hear things you weren't expecting
and that kind of trains you to,
to not panic when you hear things that
you don't understand,
to just relax.
And notice the things that you do
understand to use all of the cues,
all of the signals that help you
understand including intonation,
including,
um,
including context,
including body language,
all that stuff.
You just want to train yourself to
notice the things that help you
understand and ignore the stuff that
doesn't.
That's why it's good to,
to practice in an uncontrolled the
context with native speakers so that you
are doing that with the native sounds of
the language.
All right,
so those are my pieces of advice for how
to improve listening comprehension.
It's not rocket science.
You just need to do it every day.
There are tons of resources on the
Internet.
You can use radio,
you can use videos,
you can watch youtube,
all that stuff.
Get a teacher through I talky or some
service like that.
Speak with people and use subtitles when
you watch videos.
Subtitles.
Not all the time,
but there are a good tool to help you
connect the visual and the auditory.
All right.
I hope that made sense.
Hope that was helpful.
Have a good night.
Talk to you.
[inaudible].